die Generation Z Generation Z das sind
die Leute die nach 1996 geboren wurden
ich gehöre nicht dazu ich wurde 1991
geboren möchte aber trotzdem heute
einmal eine Lanze brechen für diese
Generation es wird immer wieder gesagt
sie ist faul sie ist nur noch am Handy
und in den sozialen Medien unterwegs die
will nicht richtig arbeiten sie hat
keine Loyalität mehr zum Arbeitgeber und
es wird eigentlich nur auf dieser
Generation rumgehakt aber wer ist diese
Generation eigentlich es ist eine
Generation die in Corona extrem schlecht
behandelt wurde wir haben vorhin über
Jens Spahn geredet der war
Gesundheitsminister und hat die Schulen
geschlossen und diese Generation konnte
nicht mehr in die Schule gehen und jetzt
halten wie ihr vor sie sei faul dieser
komisch sie sei ein bisschen vom Weg
abgekommen die Wahrheit ist wir haben
nur diese Generation um uns in die
Zukunft zu tragen diese Generation kann
mit dem Internet umgehen sie ist
international sie ist vernetzt sie weiß
was sie tut und ich glaube wir müssen
viel mehr Vertrauen in die
Generationszeit haben
Viktor letztens habe ich auf LinkedIn
ein Posting gesehen da war ein junge
Frau die hat studiert hatte zwei Jahre
Arbeitserfahrung hat dann gepostet von
ihrem sebattical da stand sie vorm
Schiff auf Weltreise Hände nach oben und
ja wir sind ja nicht so dumm wie die
alten Generation da habe ich schon
innerlich gedacht ob man jetzt nach zwei
Jahren Berufserfahrung und einem Studium
wirklich schon eine zweite Weltreise
oder ein Bett gebraucht das würdest Du
auch beantragen ich glaube es ist
wichtig zu gucken was braucht ein Mensch
ganz individuell um weiterzukommen und
wenn diese Person das Gefühl hatte ja
ich brauche jetzt meinen ja raus das
muss jetzt halt sein die persönlichen
Umstände kennen wir nicht da muss man
das ernst nehmen denn die Generation
Zeit hat gelernt darüber nachzudenken
und zu kommunizieren was sie will was
sie braucht um weiter zu machen und wir
wissen aus der Baby Boomer Generation
aus den Generationen die danach kommen
aus den Millennials dazu gehören wir
beide dass viele Leute sich auch
übernehmen und dass das hinterher mehr
Produktivität einschränkt und mehr
Verluste kreiert die Weltreise vor dem
übernehmen damit gar nicht ins Risiko
kommt sich vielleicht zu übernehmen also
eine Weltreise da ging es glaube ich
nichts anzuwenden sollte jeder mal
gemacht haben aber sich zu übernehmen
das passiert schneller als man denkt und
wir müssen ich sage nicht dass jeder ins
Bett gehen machen soll aber wir müssen
den Leuten zuhören und gucken was sind
denn individuelle Bedürfnisse und kann
man den gerecht werden oder nicht Herr
Kessler die Anne Will die Talkshow
masterin hat mal gesagt in einem Podcast
das gerade in der Jugend man sich doch
so richtig reinwerfen kann und auch so
richtig reinwerfen sollte und das würde
wäre doch toll wenn man sich damit Werft
in seinen Beruf stürzt das ist ja
eigentlich was die Generation selbst
will das Gegenargument also ich bin
immer etwas skeptisch bei solchen
Situationen zu schreiben ich bin ja ein
alter Weise Mann und da gab es da mal
die Generation Golf und dachte ich mir
auch machen die alte dasselbe jetzt äh
wie das damals beschrieben worden ist
natürlich auch nicht so ne es letztens
kommt auf individuelle Lebensentwürfe an
und dennoch gibt's eine gemeinsame
Kunden Melodie Generation
genau und da muss man schon sagen dass
zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit und auch
abgefragt im Studium doch einen Sound
dominiert der eben self care in den
Vordergrund stellt also war klar um sich
selbst kümmern ja viel Geld weiß
vielleicht nicht aber dass man eher sagt
so viel Geld brauche ich vielleicht gar
nicht ich erhole erstmal dann arbeite
ich und ich glaube das schöne ist ja
wirklich da würde ich ja Frau will in
dem Fall sogar recht geben dass
natürlich total viel Power hat total
viel Neugier total viel Möglichkeiten
physisch wie psychisch als junger Mensch
und man wird natürlich sagen mach lieber
jetzt mal eine Reise wo du auch was für
dich selber lernst wohl auch Arbeiten
vielleicht lernen würde auch
Möglichkeiten hast dich produktiv zu ähm
während als ich zurückzuziehen und das
glaube ich so ein bisschen momentan das
Problem an der jenset Oder Generation Z
dass man sagt also mein persönliches
Wohlbefinden muss erstmal geklärt sein
dann müsst ihr euch anstellen also
gewissermaßen der der Arbeitnehmer als
König bei dem die Arbeitgeber sich
anzustellen haben es gab früher Exzesse
das will ich gar nicht bestreiten aber
dieses extreme Anspruchs denken über ist
jetzt ständig in die Öffentlichkeit
geblasen bekommen im Sinne von ich mache
mal halblang Arbeit ist nicht das
wichtig zu leben ja da würde ich auch
zustimmen ist nicht das Wichtigste im
Leben aber wir brauchen eine gute
Grundlage und uns steckt allen sehr viel
diese Kräfte sollten wir wecken sein
statt sie verschlimmern zu lassen früher
hieß es immer lehrjahre sind keine
Herrenjahre das ist doch so und sollte
so sein das ist heute auf einem weit
höheren Niveau ich bin inzwischen
Großvater und weiß dass meine
Enkelkinder andere Voraussetzungen haben
als ich sie hatte und das ist auch gut
so dass sie die entsprechend haben aber
dennoch ist es immer darauf anzulegen
dass es eine Verantwortung fürs eigene
Leben ist und dass dieses auch nicht nur
ich ist Mensch ist sowohl Individuum als
auch sozial Natur und wer sich nur so
denkt dass er nicht für einen
Gemeinschaft mit drin steht und dafür
eintritt wird scheitern damit wir die
gesamte Gesellschaft scheitern hätten
sie ein Problem damit wenn sie ihre
Enkel auf die Straße kleben oder bei
Fridays for future mitlaufen dann würde
ich mir vorwerfen dass ich nicht genug
mit ihnen diskutiert habe aber wenn Sie
zu den Entscheidung kommen
Kinder und Enkelkinder sollte man nicht
politisch manipulieren sondern durch
Beispiel da sein und wenn es bei einem
jemand anders läuft ist es auch gut auch
nicht gut
aber ich hätte schon Schwierigkeiten
wenn ein Kind oder Enkelkind von mir bei
der AFD wäre dann hätte ich schon sehr
ernsthafte Probleme und würde mir
Vorwürfe machen was ich vielleicht
falsch gemacht habe 4 Tage Woche machen
will aber dann ist das etwas anderes so
genau kann man darüber kann man
diskutieren wenn das vom Arbeitsablauf
stimmt das ist aber eine rechnerische
frage ich sie bisher keine Wirtschaft
sinnvolle Lösung außerdem geht es nur
darum dass es insgesamt über
Tarifvertrag insgesamt geht und nicht
ich meine eigene persönliche
Entscheidung allein treffe die Welt geht
nicht nur nach Individuum sondern wie es
insgesamt funktioniert in einer
Verantwortung und das muss glaube ich
entsprechend gesehen werden und diese
Frage muss ich auch sehen wie es
weitergeht beklagen dann wir kriegen
nachher keine Rente mehr übrigens als
ich 20 oder 25 Jahre wusste gar nicht
wie das Wort Rente geschrieben wird
keine Gedanken darüber gemacht das ist
darüber wird jetzt geredet aber wer
jetzt auf auf ein Jahr auf Tour geht hat
natürlich nicht mit für 63 Anspruch auf
eure Rente weil er zu wenig eingezahlt
da kommt der arbeitet mit 30 voll Herr
Bro ich habe eine ganz spannende Studie
mitgebracht und zwar am häufigsten liest
die Generation X gefolgt von Generation
why und jetzt kommt die Generation
selbst liest am wenigsten und zwar auch
nur noch 62 % täglich und der Kiste ich
glaube ja dass sie viel lesen
absolut ja was passiert denn mit der
Schreibkompetenz mit der Lesekompetenz
weil das ist ja auch laut der Studie
gegeben dass sie gerne Operation Set zu
wenig liest ich könnte diese Zahlen
jetzt nicht aber sie denken sie ja mit
befunden dass die Lese und Kompetenzen
Verständnis Kompetenz bei jungen
Menschen abnimmt und ich finde man lernt
nur schreiben man lernt nur denken durch
Lesen man beheimatet sich so in einer
Kultur in dem man liest in dem man sich
auch Kunstwerke betrachtet indem wir
also den eigenen Horizont auch erweitert
und ich glaube schon dass man davon
abkommen muss zu sagen der Gradmesser
der Dinge der ich mich aussetze ist mir
gut tut das war ich am Anfang oftmals
nicht oft tun aber auch Dinge tut die
einem am Anfang sehr herausfordern die
vielleicht auch eine Belastung sind die
man vielleicht mehrfach tun muss damit
man sie lernt und da darf man natürlich
nicht zu früh die Flinte ins Korn werfen
und vor allen Dingen glaube ich muss mal
wirklich schauen was ist mein Lebensweg
der mich auch glücklich machen ich
glaube auf Dauer macht dich nur
glücklich wenn du eine produktive
Tätigkeit hast und durch diese
produktive Tätigkeit Selbstbestätigung
bekommen das heißt sie sagen dass die
nicht produktiv sind verstehst richtig
ich halte es für ein falsches Foto wenn
man sagen würde die Produktivität wird
in Bayern und 8 gestellt und ist gar
nicht mehr so wichtig sind sehr
wichtiger Faktor und wenn man sagt ich
will ein Lebensweg haben der wie soll
ich sagen der Laune des jeweiligen Tag
ist untergeordnet ist dann hielt es für
ein großes Problem ist manchmal da aber
man kann es nicht so pauschal sagen also
da muss ich ein Wachs bei
ursprünglich kenne sehr viele auch junge
Menschen die die sehr sehr viel und sehr
sehr gern arbeiten klar die Beispiele
die hier eingeblendet waren waren ja
vielleicht auch eher Vertreter ich sag
mal das andere lebensbildes und
grundsätzlich muss natürlich festhalten
wenn wir in der Tat ich sag das vorhin
über 2 Millionen beispielsweise über 2
Millionen offene Stellen sprechen in
Deutschland
dann kann natürlich die junge Generation
hat einen ganz andere Auswahlmöglichkeit
ja also anders als zu Zeiten von
Massenarbeitslosigkeit wo ähm wo der
einzelne auch ein ganz anderen Druck
hatte irgendwo sich eine Arbeit zu
suchen und dort dann halt auch
entsprechend Leistung zu bringen das
werden wir nicht wegkriegen durch
molarisieren oder durch durch
andere Form irgendwo das ist
Zeigefingers sondern am Ende des Tages
ist diese Generation in einem Wohlstand
aufgewachsen der aber das hatte ich da
vorher auch gesagt so bestimmt nicht
befürchte ich Bestand haben wird diese
Generation halt niemals eine
diese tiefe Rezession außer halt
irgendwo harter kurze Einschnitte wie
bei Corona oder jetzt auch beim Krieg in
der Ukraine Finanzkrise 2018 aber die
Finanzkrise 2008 hat waren die Leute
neulich im Arbeitsmarkt nee aber die
Wissen von ihren Eltern wie was
assistenzangst bedeutet die wissen schon
was aber
deswegen nicht so viel arbeiten müssen
nein aber
wir dürfen nur nicht unterschätzen was
sie von der Welt gesehen haben und was
sie verstehen und wenn die sagen damit
ich funktionieren kann im Arbeitsmarkt
muss ich jetzt mal einen Tag weniger
arbeiten da muss halt mehr Fachkräfte
anwerben wir machen jetzt am Ende wieder
wir machen mal zum Ende deiner These ein
Test mit dir jetzt welche Generation du
eigentlich gehört und zwar was hast du
als letztes gelesen heute nee welches
Buch hast du zuletzt gelesen die
Bild-Zeitung habe ich zuletzt gelesen
gefunden sehr loyal FDP sehr loyal